- All right, we have just
enough time for one more story.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Carol Burnett is a living legend.
We saw that all hour.
She's incredibly funny,
but just as important,
she's opened doors for countless
women in entertainment.
That's not a surprise
according to the founder of Funny Girls.
Funny Girls is a groundbreaking
program under the umbrella
of the Harnisch Foundation
that teaches young girls
leadership skills through comedy.
They say being funny
makes you a better leader.
I agree.
Here to explain how it works
is the creator of Funny Girls
and executive director for the
Harnisch Foundation, Jenny.
Everybody give it up for Jenny.
(audience clapping)
What's up, Jenny?
So how does comedy make stronger leaders?
How do you think?
- So, we use improv comedy games
which is making up characters
and plots on the spot
as a fun way to practice
leadership skills.
And it's the training
and practice of those leadership skills
which lets girls know
their voice is important.
They deserve to be seen and heard.
So that's why we're working with third
to eighth grade girls at
that time when research shows
that girls start to lose their confidence.
So we're not teaching
the girls to be comedians
like the legendary Carol Burnett.
Happy birthday.
Although that would be
amazing if it happened.
But we're teaching them to be leaders,
confident people who aren't
afraid to be seen and heard.
- Absolutely.
I think it's important too to point out
that you kinda have them
do silly exercises, right?
- Yeah.
Some of the exercises are incredibly silly
and funny to watch.
And the first one we try
and you can try this at
home, is Pet Peeve Rant.
You just start ranting
about something that really annoys you,
and you start one at a time
and then everybody adds
their big complaint.
Then we turn it into a
huge chorus of complaining
and it's always super funny
to hear what annoys people,
like singing off-key or
sandwiches cut in the wrong shape.
We let them go for a minute,
cut them off and say,
"You just did improv."
And they have.
They came up with their own
material at a moment's notice.
They all succeed because
everybody has a pet peeve
and that game teaches the leadership skill
of self-awareness,
of being able to identify and
express your own emotions.
So, we're practicing and
learning leadership skills
at the same time that we're laughing
and having a ton of fun.
- Oh my gosh, I love Pet Peeve Rant.
If I didn't already have
a title for my next album
it would've been called "Pet Peeve Rant."
(audience laughing)
Would've fit perfectly.
Thank you so much, Jenny.
I'm loving what you're doing right now.
I'm liking your post, all right.
(audience clapping)
- [Jenny] Thank you.
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
love how Funny Girls
and the Harnisch Foundation
are making a difference.
It's super important.
So they're gonna be writing the foundation
a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping)
- Wow, that's so generous.
Thank you.
- Thank you for joining us
and also a big thank you
to Carol Burnett hanging
out with us all hour
and some Colbie Caillat.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.